welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Alex def of political science at Yale
professor Deb's his research interests
include the political economy of
dictatorship development and war his
work has appeared in the journal of the
history of economic thought today we'll
talk with Professor Deb's about his
newest paper living by the sword and
dying by the sword leadership
transitions in and out of dictatorships
welcome professor Deb's thank you it's a
pleasure to be here so give us an
overview of your paper so this pay in
this paper i'm trying to address the
following questions what explains the
length of tenure of dictators and what
explains the process by which they lose
office is it violent or nonviolent do
they end in leaving office and in jail
or are they killed or are they able to
walk free and I think these are
interesting questions because we think
of dictatorships as regimes which are
which have relatively weak institutions
where the leader is not but not very
accountable if we compare them to
dictatorships and the leader can remain
in office unless he's threatened by the
use of violence but there is quite a bit
of variation in cases where the leader
where violence is actually used against
the leader or whether the leader is able
to walk free and so that's what I was
trying to understand and looking at
those questions so what are some of the
key findings in your paper well what's
quite interesting is that what we find
is if we look within dictatorships
military dictators or those who have the
shortest tenure and this is something
that we had a handle on in the
literature but quite surprisingly
they're one they're the ones who have
the worst fate upon leaving office and
that's something that was quite
surprising to me because in our
understanding of dictatorships we would
think that it would be the opposite
because we think of Miller military
dictatorships as dictatorships where the
elites are united and that was the
reason I was given for why they 10
to leave office fast because they want
to avoid a fight they don't like to
fight against each other and they don't
like to fight an uprising and so that
would be an explanation for why regimes
are short and another explanation for
the shortness of regimes is that
military dictators are good at
preserving their fate after they leave
office they have this advantage in
violence and so they don't mind leaving
office because they can secure good
rents after leaving office and so when
we look at the evidence it actually
shows that it's the opposite that
military dictators fair the worst when
they leave office and that was something
that was quite intriguing to me and so I
wanted to get a handle on what explains
that phenomenon okay and how did you
come to write the paper well the project
which I was writing before this one was
co-authored with a colleague of mine at
the University of Rochester hayan
Gorman's and the question we were
looking at was what explains the
Democratic peace and the Democratic
peace is this finding that democracies
are reluctant to fight wars against each
other and there were quite a number of
explanations and quite a lot of
empirical work but there were two pieces
that were missing and trying to build
theories which were how the war outcome
affects the fate of the leader whether
he's able to remain in office whether
he's rewarded for winning or punished
for losing and the extent of that
punishment is a leader sent to jail or
killed or is he able to walk free after
leaving office and so when we looked at
the differences between the dictatorship
and democracy we found some pattern
looking at the post tenure fate of
leader and when we dug a little deeper
that's where we also found differences
within dictatorships between the
military dictators and the non military
dictators where the military dictators
fair the worst and so that really piqued
my attention and made me think about
what could explain this finding okay and
how did you gather the data for the
paper you know I'm sitting here
wondering gee how many dictators are
there throughout the world right so the
data that we were looking at was in the
post-world war two period between 1946
and 1996 and there
about 480 dictators in power at any
point in during that period when were
ousted domestically and so the data you
know a big chunk of the data exercise
was to combine two data sets one was by
my co-authored which looked at the post
tenure fate of leaders are they okay
exiled jailed or killed up to a year
after leaving office and the second data
said was the data set that codified
leaders as dictatorships or democracies
and within the dictatorships which type
is that a military dictator a monarch or
a civilian dictator and so the work that
we did in large part was merging those
two pieces of information but there was
quite a bit more work involved in that
and the codification of regimes there
were a lot of missing observations for
example if a leader comes into office
and leaves within the same year that's
an observation that would be missed in
that codification of regimes and quite a
lot of leaders fall into that category
so we had to basically take the codebook
in and look through the history of cases
and try to see which leaders would match
to what category here okay and you
applied your model to the African
country of lasoo to tell us about it
well so this country gives us a nice
case study to look at the logic of the
model because it has a relatively simple
political history in the sense that the
it was only ruled by three dictators
between independence and democratization
so between 1966 in 1993 so we can look
at how long each leader has remained in
office what has helped them remaining in
a remain in office and and whether the
process of their replacement was violent
or not and so we find the first leader
was a civilian chief Jonathan who was in
office for 20 years and you would think
well if he was in office that long he
may have been particularly powerful
leader but he was actually a very weak
leader and the only the only point that
triggered his ouster was when he
actually wanted to assert assert his
power against the military in the
military worried that he would contract
concentrate power in his hands then
decided to depose him but they deposed
him and let him walk free and in fact
you you hear accounts about leaders who
were upset after chief jonathan speaks
against the new regime and saying you
know why isn't he grateful that we saved
his life we could have killed him he his
regime was repressive and we could have
applied violence against them so you see
that he remain in office despite being
relatively weak and the next leader was
a military dictator laconia who remain
in office only for five years and during
that period this was a period where
different factions of the military would
compete against each other and he
eliminated political opponent opponents
for crimes which they may have been
involved in but may not have been the
only people responsible for and he when
he was ousted it was by other members of
the military who forced him at gunpoint
to announce at the national radio that
he was leaving office members of the
military who were sympathetic to him try
to put him back in office this failed
and the new leaders understanding that
he represented a threat put him under
house arrest and so just these two
examples give you a sense that having
some strength is that can actually be
not a blessing but the opposite for a
leader in that dis leader represent a
threat for the next leader and he might
actually fare worse fate and so that
gives you an inkling to the answer to
the question why military leaders have
this worse fate upon leaving office it's
because they represent threats to the
new leaders and so that's why they would
be either jail or killed so that they're
eliminated as political opponents okay
and so what is the conclusion you reach
in your paper well so the conclusion is
that the one key factor in understanding
the length of tenure of dictators is
understanding that the advantage for
violence is something that's transient
and maybe a military dictator is someone
who's relatively strong overall but
there are moments where he will lose the
advantage for violence and in those
cases these challenges will want to
eliminate him as a political player and
so understanding this fact about
violence
make can give us a handle on why these
leaders which we think of as strong
actually those who have the shortest
tenure because when challengers have an
opportunity they will want to eliminate
them and why once they rousted they were
sent to jail or killed and so yes sir so
I think this gives us an answer to the
initial puzzles about the length of
tenure in the post tenure fate of
dictators okay and in doing the research
for your paper what was one of the most
surprising things you found well so
there's there's quite a bit of work on
how leaders are able to manage the
transition from a dictatorship to a
democracy and what I was expecting would
be to find how military dictators fair a
lot worse than their non military
counterparts when they leave office to a
Democrat but in fact the the difference
on that level is not very high the most
important difference is when dictators
leave office to another dictator and
that's where we find that military
dictators are a lot more likely to be
jailed or killed in their non military
counterparts so that's something I
wasn't expecting from what the scholarly
literature that said about dictatorships
okay well thank you so much for being
here today and sharing some of your
research thank you for more information
about professor Deb's and his work
please visit our website at yale edu
backslash macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you